ARTUR OLIVEIRA: Thank you
all so much for coming.
My name is Artur.
And I am really
excited today to be
able to welcome Evangeline Lilly
to Google in Mountain View.
As you all know,
Evangeline is an incredibly
famous and successful actress.
She's been in plenty of works
on the big screen and on TV.
But today we're here to
talk about her new book--
first published work,
which is incredible,
"The Squickerwonkers."
And just to let you
guys know, we're
going to be doing a little bit
of Q&A and then we'll open up.
There's a mic in the back.
So if you have any questions,
feel free to come up.
And with that being said,
thank you for coming.
EVANGELINE LILLY: Yeah.
It's a pleasure to be here.
You guys are a better looking
group than the New York group.
[LAUGHTER]
Don't tell them I said so.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: This
is going to go up
on YouTube, just so you know.
EVANGELINE LILLY:
I'm never going
to be invited back to New York.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: So tell me
a little bit about the book.
I'm sure everybody would
love to hear about that.
EVANGELINE LILLY: Oh, I'm
sure everybody would really
like to hear about
other things, but I'm
going to talk about the book.
[LAUGHS] So I wrote this
book when I was 14 years old.
Well, I didn't write this book.
I wrote a poem called
"The Squickerwonkers"
when I was 14 years old.
And I carried it around
with me for 20 years,
with my mom asking me
periodically through those 20
years, (NEW YORK
ACCENT) when are you
going to publish "The
Squickerwonkers," honey?
(NORMAL VOICE) She's
not New Yorkian.
But for some reason
when you play a mom,
it just works so much better
when you use a New York accent.
And I mean, I've been
pining after the notion
of becoming a writer
for a very long time.
For any of you who have
ever watched me in interview
during my acting
gigs, you know I'm
sort of a reluctant actress,
and do it is a day job,
but my passion is writing.
So this is a crazy
momentous moment for me
to be a published author, and
to be talking about my book.
And it means the world to me.
And I've poured three years of
full-time work into this book.
And it's the first of 18 in
a series of Squickerwonker
stories for your kids, and
apparently for their kids.
Because by the time
I'm on book 18,
they'll be having children also.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: I was saving
the 18 books in the series--
EVANGELINE LILLY: Sorry.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: --question
for a little bit later.
No, no, this is great.
EVANGELINE LILLY:
Jumped the gun.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA:
Did Peter Jackson
have anything to do with this?
Or was he like--
[LAUGHTER]
--three is not enough.
EVANGELINE LILLY: Because
it's 18 books, is that why?
I was honored to have
Peter and his partners,
Fran Walsh and Philippa Boyens,
write the forward for the book.
When I was working
on "The Hobbit"
is when I first started
working on this story.
And I would bring
proofs to them to look
at-- Philippa and Fran-- who
have written the films that you
all know and love.
"The Lord of the Rings" trilogy
and "The Hobbit" trilogy.
They helped me edit the book.
I was the luckiest
first time author
in the world to be surrounded
by the incredible talent
that I was when I was making it.
And actually, I found him
through working on "The Hobbit"
also, because he worked
at the Weta Workshop who
create all of the creative--
they create the armor,
they create a lot of the
elements of the costume,
and they do the concept design
for all of Pete's movies.
So he was a very,
very lucky find.
For any of you who have
the book in your hands,
you'll have already seen that
the illustrations are out
of this world.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: Yeah,
the illustrations really
are amazing, for
those of you who
haven't had a chance
to see it yet.
EVANGELINE LILLY: Actually,
speaking of which,
this is probably a perfect
segue into this little thing
right here, which is
a Johnny Fraser-Allen
original watercolor.
This is one of the two-page
spreads in the book.
But this is the watercolor
version that's non-digitized.
So it's not quite as vibrant
as what you see in the book.
And it's going to
be prints of these,
and prints of the
illustrations are
being sold by the National
Museum for American
Illustration, because they were
so impressed with the artwork
in the book, they wanted
to display it in some way.
They wanted to participate
in it in some way.
So that was an incredible
honor for our book
to be recognized by that museum.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: It really
is a great combination
of your rhymes with his artwork.
I mean, the book is beautiful.
And as you were saying, it's
not just for children, right?
It's for children of all ages.
EVANGELINE LILLY: Yeah,
I mean, my son's three.
The publishers have
to give a demographic.
So they say five to eight.
My son's three and I'm
35, and we both love it.
So it's for everybody.
Even my 13-year-old niece,
when I was testing it,
I had her read it.
And she read it through,
and she was like, yeah,
it's really good.
It's great.
And then suddenly she
got really sheepish
in her teenage pre-teen way,
and she was like, wait a minute.
Aunty, is this a book for kids?
And I said, yeah, it's
technically a book for kids.
And I could see her
expression was mortified.
So I went, but it's cool
if older people like it.
I mean, I like it.
And she was like, oh, thank
god, because I really like it,
and it's really embarrassing
if it's a kid's book.
I want one.
So that's my teenage
niece's testimony
that it's for kids of all ages.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: Another
thing I think is interesting
that I've read you
say about the book
and about writing in general is
that it's your true passion--
EVANGELINE LILLY: Yeah.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: --correct?
And I think, to me, what's
fascinating is you're already
so successful with your acting--
EVANGELINE LILLY:
Don't be so greedy.
[LAUGHTER]
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: How does
that translate into writing?
Because you have something
that's established.
You have something
that people know you--
they know you through
that kind of work.
Can you talk a little bit
about that transition process,
and what it's like
now to start writing
and finally coming out to the
public with your first work?
EVANGELINE LILLY:
Well, I think there's
a lot of fatigue and
intolerance surrounding
actors and their pet projects.
And I think a lot of people
go, oh, yeah, OK, another actor
wants to be a singer.
Or another actor
wants to be a writer.
Or another actor wants
to be a director.
And I think that a big
part of that is probably
because what people
probably don't realize
is that actors in the film
and television industry
have no control over anything
of the creative building
of the projects that they work--
I mean, very rarely anyway.
If you're Brad Pitt,
you do, because you're
producing your own projects.
But most of us don't.
And most of us are
very creative people.
In my case, it's not just
creative frustration.
It's that acting
happened by accident.
And I was fortunate enough
to stumble into a job
that pays really well,
and that a lot of people
would dream of doing.
And it just was a
happen chance thing.
And it wasn't because it
was a passion of mine.
It wasn't because I was
desperate to be an actress.
So what I do love and
what I have always
done and been passionate about
since I was a little girl
is writing stories.
As this book is a testimony to,
since I wrote it when I was 14.
So this isn't so much a
passion project for me,
as a genuine attempt to
change career trajectories.
I mean, I've had the
disadvantage of publishers
thinking-- assuming-- that
I'm probably not very serious,
and not taking me as seriously
because I am an actress.
And then the advantage of
filling a room full of Google
employees because they want
to talk to me about "Lost."
[LAUGHTER]
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: I mean,
obviously the book
was published recently.
But you've also got
the interactive version
on iBook, which seems
like it's great for kids.
And you've got the audio
book on audible.com.
And it's just in a lot
of different places.
To you, how do you
envision people
interacting with your book?
How do you envision
them reading it?
EVANGELINE LILLY: Johnny and I
both come from the film world,
so we couldn't help ourselves.
We made a stop
animation film on paper.
And that's how we envision it.
And that's where eventually
I think-- I hope-- ultimately
it will end up on a screen
of some sort, small or large.
But I'm impatient,
and controlling.
And I couldn't
wait, so I started
making elements of
the film already.
I partnered with a composer, and
we made a Squickers soundtrack.
I partnered with Sylvester
McCoy-- some of you
know who he is.
He's Radagast in "The Hobbit."
And he was also one of
the original Doctor Whos.
He did the voice work
for the audio book
and the interactive book.
And then I kind of brought it to
life a little bit on an iBook,
so that children can
interact with it.
And there's pop-up videos
where I talk to kids, saying,
if you're a bit confused--
because this book is crazy--
let's talk about these topics.
And it was just basically
me wanting more.
I wanted a multimedia
experience with my own book.
And I now am obsessed
with the idea
that they have to go together.
I'm giving away the audio
book for free on audible.com
right now until December
1st, because I'm
so desperate for people to read
the book with everything else,
with the sound
and the narration.
And I just think they go
so beautifully together.
And the music really
brings the story to life.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: Something
I mentioned earlier
is your writing, it
really is beautiful.
EVANGELINE LILLY: You're going
to take up all their question
time.
He's getting greedy.
I'm telling you.
This is going to be the
shortest talk I've ever given.
We have very little time.
You're busy people.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: Right.
I'm sorry.
I should've had a clock
to keep me honest.
EVANGELINE LILLY: We have
another seven minutes
before we have to
start a signing.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: Oh my gosh!
OK, that flew by.
I really do apologize.
You're right.
Let's get some live questions.
And I just wanted to say,
"The Squickerwonkers",
do you want to--
just 30-second--
where does the name come from?
EVANGELINE LILLY:
When I was a kid,
I was totally obsessed
with Dr. Seuss.
And I just loved his
irreverent use of language.
I loved the fact that he made up
words if he didn't have a word.
And I, being a teenager,
was like, well, he
can make up words.
I can make up words.
So I started making up a list
of quirky, kooky, weird words.
And one of them just
jumped off the page for me
and stuck in my mouth.
And it was Squickerwonker.
And I thought, well,
what's a Squickerwonker?
So I ended up making up a poem
about the Squickerwonkers,
which are a family of
misfit marionette puppets.
But originally they
weren't puppets.
Hi, doggy.
Originally, they were
just human, but not human.
I didn't know how
that would look.
It was Johnny
Fraser-Allen who brought
the idea of the
marionette puppets.
But there was this
clan of Squickerwonkers
that I wrote a poem for.
And it just stuck.
And I still love the word.
I just think it feels fun
to say-- Squickerwonker.
I could say it 100 times.
I really like it.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: Thank you.
EVANGELINE LILLY: So there
is a microphone in the back.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: Yeah,
the mic is open.
So if anyone would like
to ask questions, please.
And I'm sure
Evangeline would love
to keep talking about the book.
EVANGELINE LILLY: Yeah, but
I'm tolerant and graceful.
I know I'm going to get a
few wild cards in there.
AUDIENCE: Well, I think somebody
has to ask this, so I will.
Jack or Sawyer?
EVANGELINE LILLY:
By the way, I knew
he was going to ask a "Lost"
question, because when
I brought up "Lost,"
he laughed harder
than anybody else in the crowd.
A girl doesn't kiss and tell.
[LAUGHTER]
Have any of you
actually read the book?
Have you had a chance to yet?
Nobody.
That's cool.
I mean, normally I come,
and people have read it.
So I'm like, oh, you
guys are in for a treat.
It's in the back.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm Rose.
I am wondering, are you going to
stick with the same art style?
Or are you going to do
different art for each book
if it's such a long series?
EVANGELINE LILLY:
Well, my plan is
to stick with the
same art style.
I feel like once
it's identifiable,
you want it to remain
identifiable with the brand.
But I don't know if I can
convince Johnny Fraser to stick
with me for 20 years.
So we'll have to see.
I certainly wouldn't
stray too far
from what has been
already established.
It's been really,
really well received.
People seem to love it.
I love it.
And, for me, it's a great
representation of the world.
So, yeah, my plan
would be to stay
as close to what you
see now as possible.
I imagine it'll evolve--
all things do, don't they?
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
I was wondering, you started
it when you were 13 or so.
And 20 odd years later, how
has your maturing and your work
in film and all of that,
how has that perspective
altered your
13-year-old Evangeline?
EVANGELINE LILLY: Well,
when I first wrote it,
it was just a traditional
cautionary tale,
where- actually, it
wasn't really even.
Let's put it this way, at
13, it was devoid of message
and moral.
It was just silly.
It was just a silly poem.
And when I started the rewrites,
which became extensive--
I rewrote it probably 30, 35
times in the last three years.
I suddenly was a mom.
And I was a grown woman, who
had been through a lot more life
experiences.
And now, suddenly, I was trying
to infuse the story with all
of these life
lessons I'd learned,
and all of these ideas
about the world--
essentially, my world view.
And one of things I went out
of my way to do with this story
is to break away from the
traditional children's
storybook model, where there
are good guys and bad guys.
And the good guys are us,
and the bad guys are them.
And the good guys live
happily ever after,
and the bad guys get killed.
Because I just think
that that's a worldview
that perpetuates starvation,
and war and fighting
and imbalance and injustice.
And I feel like children live
in a much more balanced world
than that, believe it or not.
We all seem to have negative
things about ourselves,
and positive things
about ourselves.
In my 35 years on
this planet, I've
never met a villain,
not face to face anyway.
Not that I know of.
I've heard about them.
And so the characters are all
partly good and partly bad.
There's positive
things about them
and negative things about them.
And our protagonist, who is
this adorable little girl who's
very pretty on the outside,
is very ugly on the inside.
And she gets herself into a
lot of trouble because of that.
And our other protagonist,
the Squickerwonkers,
who are these puppets
who we're going
to follow through 18
books-- who are so
truly our protagonists--
they look ugly,
they look creepy and weird,
they have all kinds of vices,
but there are
elements of them that
are fun and lovable, and
unique and interesting.
And it's really a book to help
children and their parents
explore those ideas together
and talk about-- you
can know that there
are things that aren't
great about yourself and still
be lovable, because everybody's
like that, even mom and dad.
But let's talk about
the consequences of some
of your actions, and how
you can prevent yourself
from falling to harm because
of those things about you.
I'm telling you, I'm
not going to get mad
if you ask about
"Lost" or "The Hobbit."
[LAUGHTER]
I know you have questions.
And you don't have to
use the microphone.
I could hear you.
Oh, wait, sound are
probably going to kill me.
No, you have to go
back to the microphone.
Sorry.
Do you want to use mine?
Come, you can use mine.
You can talk into my lap.
AUDIENCE: It's about
the book actually.
[LAUGHTER]
If you have--
EVANGELINE LILLY: Stop talking
to my boobs and talk to me.
AUDIENCE: If you have 18 books
that you're going to write,
do you already know
the storylines,
or are they still evolving?
EVANGELINE LILLY: Thank you.
[LAUGHTER]
If you're of the male
gender, you can't use my lap.
I know what all of them
will be, so I'm not
shooting from the hip.
A lot of people who
watched my show "Lost"
complained that they thought
our authors, our writers,
were always doing that.
And I'm not doing that.
I have a very clear idea
of what the books are.
The Demise series, which
is the first series
I'll come out with-- which
is a series of nine books--
I know every single story.
I haven't written them
all, but I know them all.
I have written the second book.
And then the last series--
the second series--
is the origins of
the Squickerwonkers.
And that one I know what the
stories have to consist of,
I just haven't mapped
out the full book yet.
I mean, the reason it's
18 books is not arbitrary.
It has to be 18, because
that will complete the circle
and complete the story.
And I can't tell you any more,
because it'll be a spoiler.
But it's 18 for a reason, yeah.
Anyone else?
We've only got one minute.
You're going to
miss your chance.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: Come on.
EVANGELINE LILLY: I don't
know what was in the hatch.
I loved the ending.
[LAUGHTER]
What else can I tell you?
Being an elf is awesome.
AUDIENCE: All right,
"Hobbit" question.
Deal with it.
I understand that your
character in "The Hobbit"
was not in the original Tolkien.
Were you at all involved in
the process of figuring out
how she fits into this
world, and how she'd
be written into the
plot for the films?
EVANGELINE LILLY: OK,
first of all, when you say,
as you understand
it, are you going
to try to pretend like you
never read "The Hobbit"?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: So as I understand
it, she's not in "The Hobbit,"
but as you probably
know, there's
a lot more Tolkien mythology
that's not directly
in the books, but this
apparently still goes on.
EVANGELINE LILLY: I'm curious,
have you read "The Hobbit"?
AUDIENCE: --not in "The
Lord of the Rings",
but apparently she's in
the Tolkien universe.
EVANGELINE LILLY: Right, right.
Well, Tauriel was a
complete invention.
She's a complete
invention for the film.
I did work very closely with
Peter, Fran, and Philippa
to create her.
And I always very
tongue-in-cheek
tell people, though,
that she was in the book.
As a person who was a
massive fan of Tolkien--
and "The Hobbit" was one of
my favorite books as a kid--
she was there.
They just didn't name her.
They talk about
the Silvan Elves,
and they don't give any
of them a name or a face.
And so we just got to
meet a few of them.
So she was there
all along, you just
finally got the
privilege of getting
to know her a little bit.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
EVANGELINE LILLY: So I think
we got to start a signing,
or we're going to
run out of time.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: Thank you
all for your questions.
I'm sorry for taking
up too much time.
EVANGELINE LILLY: No, you
took a perfect amount of time.
ARTUR OLIVEIRA: But
Evangeline's been very kind.
She's going to stick
around to sign some books,
and take a picture.
There's plenty of you.
So we have limited time.
But with that, we'll
just head to the back.
EVANGELINE LILLY: Thanks
for coming, you guys.
[APPLAUSE]